[Aplausos]
el líder de la oposición juan guaidó no
podrá participar en los comicios
parlamentarios del próximo 6 de
diciembre a su partido ya varios otros
un fallo legal les quitó las tarjetas
electorales y por eso llamó al boicot y
a una consulta simbólica online para
pedir nuevas elecciones presidenciales
[Aplausos]
de diciembre en venezuela hay intentos
de fraudes de relatar y de usurpar el
parlamento por vía de los hechos la
exigencia del pueblo venezuela en
elección libre justa y verificable si yo
quisiera postular me hoy en ese proceso
no pudiera porque la dictadura lo
prohíbe al igual que a más de 400
perseguidos por el régimen la minoría
opositora que sí está habilitada a
participar son los que hacen parte de la
mesa del diálogo con nicolás maduro
los socialistas en un intento de darle
credibilidad a las elecciones
parlamentarias insisten que se
inscribieron más de 105 organizaciones
políticas y que apenas el 30 por ciento
son afectas al gobierno nacional
de las apuestas radicales de una vez
difusión mejor
de sectores de oposición a las
elecciones mientras el gobierno une sus
estrategias para recuperar la asamblea
nacional la oposición está más dividida
que nunca por una parte why do intenta
mantener su liderazgo otros opositores
pretenden actuar desde el exilio y
también están quienes se niegan a un
pacto unitario con un círculo vicioso
donde distintos que tienen diferencias
tácticas y estratégicas y eso un reto
que también tiene que hacer la oposición
porque piensan mucho en egos piensa
mucho en miran y partidos de que tiene
que hacerlo y es normal en el sentido de
que todo partido va a buscar para estar
en el poder
todo indica que el próximo 6 de
diciembre el gobierno socialista
obtendrá la mayoría de la asamblea
nacional mientras tanto la oposición que
atraviesa una división profunda se
enfrenta a un panorama incierto donde no
le quedan espacios políticos para lograr
la salida constitucional de nicolás
maduro termina fernández para las 24
caracas